kobe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai appelé un candidature d'union
d'union contre le système financier
monétaire existants pour une banque
nationale un système de crédit public un
retour de service public
évidemment cela n'a pour l'instant pas
rencontré beaucoup de succès mais cette
union est nécessaire et je me battrai
pour elle avec un vrai programme mais
sur la course à l'échalote et dans une
résidence il pour l'instant non jamais
je ne ferai jamais il ya des textes il
faut les suivre
je pense que ceux qui ont mangés dans
des restaurants clandestins se sont
moqués de la population non je ne lui ai
plus pour une conception de la culture
qui n'est pas la mienne
- la conception de la culture c b
d'ovins et à peu c'est une conception de
la culture qui n'est pas du tout celle
qui aujourd'hui les médias dominants les
politiques propage alors que le peuple
l'attend et le voudrait
[Musique]
oui j'ai regardé games of thrones
je pense que c'est extrêmement pervers
et vicieux s'est basé sur l'idée qu'elle
menace venue de l'extérieur les gens qui
sont au delà d'une rue glace et qu'en
même temps qu'elle et féodaux et il ya
des pervers financier de l'autre côté et
tout ça crée une société dans laquelle
c'est la guerre de tous contre tous
il est extrêmement pervers beaucoup plus
pervers que des scènes de violence ou
des scènes associées le sexe étudiants
ce qu'a d'ailleurs nos jeunes sont alors
le thème soit devenu un phénomène
universel c'est difficile d'intervenir à
céret menace mieux il ya des milliards 2
jours 2 3 milliards de gens qui l'ont vu
dans le jour
[Musique]